approximately
252 million years ago the earth's
biosphere suffered from a tremendous
blow
almost 96 of marine fauna around 70
percent of land vertebrates and roughly
83 percent of insects perished within a
period really short by geological
standards the causes of this disaster
are still obscure but whatever it was
the dreadful calamity didn't wipe life
off the face of the earth
quite on the contrary it proved to be a
milestone that marked the beginning of a
new era
this is when there emerged the most
well-known prehistoric creatures
dinosaurs
cosmo
the first in outer space
the permian triassic extinction event
marked the beginning of the mesozoic
a new era in the geologic history of the
earth
it began approximately
252 million years ago and continued for
around
186 million years
this was a time when our planet was
actively transforming and gradually
assuming it's today's looks
the most crucial tectonic process of the
epoch was the splitting of the single
supercontinent pangaea first it broke
down into two landmasses lorasia and
gondwana which in their turn went on to
form the continents we know today
with several large mutually independent
territories separated by seas and
straits the conditions were perfect for
independent ecosystems to emerge which
gave impetus to new evolutionary
adaptations
in terms of climate the mesozoic was the
warmest era in the entire history of
multicellular life forms
throughout this era there was no ice
shield even of the pearls that would
cover the ground for a long term
still temperature would drop from time
to time which forced both flora and
fauna to adapt to the newly imposed
conditions
the mesozoic comprises three periods and
the first one is known as the triassic
it began around
252 million years ago and continued for
around 51 million years
this was the time when tectonic
processes in the earth's interior were
just starting to break pangaea into
separate continents and the
supercontinent remained whole for most
of the period
the ural ridge one of the oldest
mountain ridges existing to this day
completed its formation in the triassic
at the time the mountains were in their
solid days and comparatively high
the period's climate was relatively dry
and hot which is why there were lots of
deserts at the time and the area of
inland bodies of water diminished there
was 10 to 15 percent of oxygen in the
air for most of the triassic and then
around 215 million years ago its level
gave a sudden leap to reach as much as
19 percent
the reasons for this phenomenon haven't
been established for certain but it is
assumed that it may have had something
to do with the evolution and spreading
of certain varieties of marine or land
plants
prehistoric seed ferns accounted for the
overwhelming majority of the flora of
the day but later on they were gradually
ousted by more progressive groups of
plants those included psyches ginkgo and
prehistoric conifers
many of these orders have survived our
day although now they're not as diverse
as they used to be
marine life meanwhile was following its
own course of evolution
the oceans emptied by the perm triassic
extinction were gradually populated by
turtles and teleasts and the first
ichthyosaurus held the niche of large
predators
later on they were to become reptiles
best adapted to aquatic environment
but in the triassic these creatures were
still rather primitive
an example of these is symbol spondulis
which lived 240 to 210 million years ago
this giant seasaurian measured 6 to 10
meters in length and date mostly fish
this impressive creature had a long thin
body half of which was a flexible tail
its head was rather large and the
elongated sharp muzzle boasted a nice
set of small and sharp teeth
symbol spondulis's limbs looked like
diving fins but it appears they were
used only to stabilize body position in
water
the thorian skeleton structure suggests
that it traveled through water by making
wave-like movements and generally
speaking was rather clumsy
the most common representatives of
landfauna of that time were raqqa soria
prehistoric ancestors of dinosaurs
crocodile amorphous and birds as well as
other animal species
by the middle of the period first
dinosaurs evolved from ancient
arcasauria as independent species but
there was still a long and hard struggle
for survival up ahead for them
it was only by the end of the triassic
that dinosaurs started to establish
their dominance in the earth's biosphere
after sharply growing in size which
incidentally coincided with an increase
of oxygen in the atmosphere
with dozens of films and thousands of
books about horrifying saurians anyone
today would be familiar with what they
looked like
at the same time these giants seem to
eclipse other species which are by no
means less important and interesting
for example oligocythus
a small creature that lived in the late
triassic around 200 million years ago
this small and deft little animal was a
genus of cyanodance prehistoric animals
that differed from mammals in some not
very clearly noticeable traits
oligocyphus had a thin flexible body
measuring around 50 centimeters
it grew fur and generally looked like a
weasel
warm blooded and herbivorous it was
widespread on the territories of today's
north america europe and china
even though it isn't known whether
oligocyphus had a pouch on its stomach
the structure of its skeleton allows us
to assume that its babies were quite
small which is typical of today's
marsupials it is also highly likely that
oligocyphus fed its babies on milk
another assumption about these creatures
is that they dug boroughs and made homes
there they also took great care about
their babies which may be evidence of a
comparatively high intellect
unfortunately these creatures perished
at the beginning of the jurassic period
supposedly due to lack of food and
heightened competition still they remain
the oldest prehistoric animals that look
like today's mammals most
the triassic jurassic mass extinction
heralded the end of the triassic period
a great number of amphibians some
arcusauria other reptiles as well as
many plant orders vanished from the face
of the earth
among the possible reasons for this
disaster of volcanic activity a change
in the global ocean level and sudden
climate change
either way the extinction event vocated
a number of ecological niches which
allowed dinosaurs to establish a firmer
position on the evolutionary arena of
the earth
the next period of the mesozoic was the
jurassic
it began about 201 million years ago and
ended about
145 million years ago which makes it
roughly 56 million years long
this was a time of large-scale tectonic
movements and reformations
it is in the jurassic that the
supercontinent pangaea finally split to
form several land masses mutually
separated by shallow seas
if we look at the map of the earth at
the end of the jurassic period we'll be
able to distinguish the shapes of some
of today's continents although they
would be positioned in unexpected places
since the new continents were mutually
independent their emerged isolated
biosystems
that is why some animals and plants that
were abundant on one continent would be
non-existent on another
the earth's climate was warm and humid
for most of the jurassic period and by
its end a comparatively short cooling
occurred
great areas on land were covered with
tropical forests which were for the most
part cycas gymnosperms to tresembled
palm trees
conifers were also widespread
their looks were reminiscent of today's
cypress trees and pine trees
on land meanwhile there started the
epoch when dinosaurs positively
flourished their diversity was rich and
they held most ecological niches while
dominating almost every single one of
them
among these creatures one could come
across both small saurians the size of a
cat and real giants
herbivorous dinosaurs known as sauropoda
came to be widespread in the jurassic
with some typical representatives like
brachiosaurus brontosaurus diplodocus
and others they resembled each other
very much
the largest one titanosaurus
measured as much as 25 to 30 meters in
length and could weigh over 75 tons
an unusual feature typical of sauropoda
is the so-called sacral brain a widening
in the hind part of the vertebrae that
hypothetically could contain 20 times
more nervous tissue than cranial brain
today it is posited that the sacral
cavity was likely to be filled with a
glycogen body which was a source of
additional nutrition for the giant
saurian's nervous system
alongside dinosaurs other animal species
were evolving as well
such as mammals
reptiles and arthropods
the oceans were richly populated with
bivalve mollusks which in many ways
resembled their today's descendants
the apex predators in the marine food
chain were various saurians like
ichthyosaurus and pliosaurus
looking at a thalmasaurus which lived at
the beginning and the end of the
jurassic period and comparing it with
symbol spondulis which lived earlier it
may be hard to believe that these
animals are in fact related
ancestor
symbol spondulous
lived 240 to 210 million years ago
length 6 to 10 meters
elongated body and head
badly adapted to aquatic environment
descendant
of thalmasaurus
lived 160 to 145 million years ago
length
up to 6 meters streamlined body
vertical tail
well adapted to aquatic environment
this marine saurian had a dolphin-like
body with an elegant and powerful
crescent-shaped vertical tail
it is thought that the animal breathed
atmospheric air and was able to stay
around 20 minutes under water develop
speeds of over seven kilometers per hour
and dive as deep as 600 meters
judging by ophthalmosol's teeth
structure its diet consisted for the
main part of mollusks including squid
the animal's eyes were another
distinctive feature in its appearance
their diameter measured around 10
centimeters and they were protected by a
bony sclerotic ring it is thought that a
thalmosaurus could see well in the dark
which was a valuable asset for deep
water hunt and so the animal was free to
dive far down where larger saurian
predators couldn't get
the last period of the mesozoic era is
called the cretaceous it began
145 million years ago and lasted for
around 79 million years which makes it
the longest one in the mesozoic
the continents continued to break apart
throughout the entire cretaceous india
detached itself from africa and slowly
drifted in the direction of asia across
the indian ocean south america broke
away as well and made its way westwards
eventually by the end of the period
africa australia greenland north and
south america assumed shapes close to
those of today while europe and asia
were starting to get clearly defined
borders
the climate in the cretaceous was
comparatively cool in the period from
100 to 85 million years ago the average
temperature increased somewhat and then
cooling continued which persisted till
the very end of the era
this is exactly when tyrannosaurus and
triceratops were around the most widely
known dinosaurs and truly distinctive
symbols of the mesozoic
still the period is much more notable
for the spread of flowering plants first
trees and then grasses
they formed turf and so strengthened the
soils and made them more fertile while
nutritious seeds served as food for a
wide variety of species
this gave evolutionary impetus to
diversification of mammal species and
also for some herbivorous dinosaurs but
on a smaller scale
even though reptiles were dominating in
all the ecological niches of that time
mammals continued to evolve
they grew to be more and more diverse
and by the end of the period it was
possible to single out separate groups
like congolets yolypo typhla predators
and primates
reponomas which lived around
125 million years ago was one of the
largest mammals of the cretaceous
its body measured up to one meter in
length and it weighed 12 to 14 kilograms
this creature's appearance may have been
similar to today's tasmanian devils
its teeth structure suggests that it was
a predator but its limbs were short and
clumsy so probably this animal was a
scavenger
incidentally an interesting find was an
earth to archaeological diggings
it was reponomous's skeleton with bits
of a small dinosaur in its abdominal
area
this may serve as evidence that some
mammals of the time could hunt small
dinosaur species like cetacosaurus and
dakyon authorities
meanwhile large aquatic saurians had
long been dominating the seas
ichthyosaurus plesiosaurus and
mosasaurus
however around 1995 million years ago
their population sharply dropped after
the extinction event brought about by
the second oceanic anoxic event which
had to do with a sharp decrease of
oxygen in the ocean one of the suggested
possible reasons is increased underwater
volcanic activity
the end of the cretaceous was probably
the coldest time in the mesozoic all
living creatures set about adapting to
the inexorably dropping temperatures
and dinosaurs were no exception
around 70 million years ago the
territory of today's northern alaska
above the arctic circle was inhabited by
peculiar dinosaur species
this sauron is known as nanuxorus
remotely related to the horrifying giant
tyrannosaurus rex this dinosaur
admittedly resembled it but its size was
smaller
the body of nanuksaurus measured around
six meters and it weighed just around a
thousand kilos that is approximately
eight nine times less than tyrannosaurus
rex
this shrinking is thought to have had to
do with a lack of available food in its
habitats
forced to survive in the dire conditions
of the far north among snowy stretches
and in the semi darkness of the polar
night this dinosaur developed some
unusual features
first of all it is likely that it was
warm blooded and incidentally the
metabolic processes in its body ran
their course remarkably fast for example
as is the case with today's birds
secondly nanuksaurus's body was covered
with several layers of down and feathers
which allowed it to preserve warmth in
the severe northern climate this
suggests that the northern saurian was
probably an active and fast-moving
predator but in the conditions of the
polar knight traditional ways of hunting
prey are not that effective that is why
it appears that nanuksaurus had an
exceptionally well developed sense of
smell and sensitive night vision
these assumptions are confirmed by the
build of its cranium
summer in northern latitudes was short
and rather cool so additional sources of
warmth were needed for dinosaur eggs so
that the babies developed well
nanuksaurus is thought to hatch its eggs
and to take great care about the young
ones studies of fossil finds show that
the volume of the brain of this species
was rather big potentially this dinosaur
was as intelligent as most of today's
birds
unfortunately these evolutionary
adaptations
didn't save nanuksaurus from extinction
around 66 million years ago the
cretaceous paleogene extinction event
caused all non-avian dinosaurs to vanish
off the face of the earth alongside
marine saurians pterosaurs and many
other species
still the terrifying saurians left their
imprint in the history of our planet and
the ecological niches vacated by them
were promptly occupied by birds and
mammals
this marked the beginning of the
cenozoic era its highest being was the
unique creature that came to be known as
homo sapiens the self-proclaimed king
above all nature
its evolution has only just started and
time will show what it has in store for
this species
dear friends if you have anything to say
about all this feel free to do so in the
comments below
your support means a world to us because
videos of this series take a lot of time
and effort to create
please subscribe to be in touch with
cosmo and we'll be happy if you give us
a like this will inspire us to produce
and post a new video faster let's keep
in touch
you